Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
There was a new interview with Chris
Evans claiming that he would come back
to the Marvel movies eventually.
So we'll break it all down.
Have been a lot
a lot of reports and rumors
about which movies he's coming back for,
what kind of cameos,
even which characters it would be,
because he's also talked about coming
back, as is Johnny Storm
from the Fantastic Four.
Having a big audience for
you must be a cool thing.
Good for you.
You made it in Seattle cause,
you know, fingers crossed.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos, really hoping that
all the strike stuff gets figured out.
Right now, everything is basically paused
in Hollywood.
So if Chris Evans
was in the middle of talks
to come back before the strike started,
they basically had to stop
that while everybody went on strike.
the only movies and TV shows being worked
on right now are the ones that were done
filming or were ready to be released
before the strike.
Like Loki, Season
two is coming out in a couple of weeks.
Of course,
they'll do episode videos for that.
But the reason
why we're getting to watch that
is because they finished it
before the strike.
so all the interviews with Chris Evans
talking about coming back
in multiple different
points were from before the strikes.
Actors aren't even really allowed to talk
about that stuff while they're on strike.
So he won't really talk about this
more probably until next year.
But everyone heard the rumor a while ago
that he'll be returning a Deadpool
three as his Johnny Storm
for a Fox Marvel Fantastic four cameo
because they're basically doing
Deadpool Kills the Fox Marvel Universe
in that movie, partially adapting it.
It's meant to be one of two big
swansong things that Kevin Vega is doing
for all the Fox Marvel characters
in legacy Marvel characters
It has been a long journey.
It really has.
It has.
It feels like it's gone by incredibly fast
I feel like we just got here.
I feel like we never even left.
I have no idea where I am in time
and space.
like all the classic X-Men actors
from the Bryan Singer movies,
the first class movies, the Fantastic
Four movies.
I don't know if that means
that there will be some cameos
from the reboot movie,
getting a lot of questions about that.
Maybe Deadpool will just clown on that
until a few jokes like the reboot actors.
some of them have gone on
since too much bigger things
like I think we're all much happier
with Michael Jordan's
version of Killmonger than we were
with his version of Johnny Storm
this is what Chris Evans said
about coming back as Johnny Storm
I mean, I don't exactly
look the same anymore.
I was 15, almost 20 years ago. Got old,
but I really love that character.
Yeah. Look, I,
I would love it with nothing.
That would actually be an easier
sell to me than coming back is cap.
You know what I mean?
Cap is so precious to me.
And, you know,
I almost don't want to disrupt
what a beautiful experience that was.
But Johnny Storm,
I feel like he didn't really get his day.
That was before
Marvel really found its footing.
So I love that role.
And, you know, who knows?
There have been so many rumors about all
the cameo scenes in Deadpool three.
There's no way that all of them will be
true.
Supposedly, Ben Affleck was even going
to do a cameo scene as his daredevil,
but then it was reported that they're
probably just doing a Jennifer Garner
Elektra cameo in Deadpool
would have so much, so much material
to clown on with even one of those actors
coming back as their characters.
It just feels like
the movie would get too overstuffed
if they brought every single legacy actor
back from the classic Marvel movies.
like most of the movie, is supposed to be
about the X-Men that are coming back.
So there's just isn't that much room
for a billion other major cameo scenes.
So we'll see if Chris Evans
shows up during that.
I think part of the reason
why people assumed that he would be in
the movie is also because he's friends
with Ryan Reynolds in Real life.
And did the Captain America
cameo scene in his Free Guy movie.
There's also supposedly how
Ryan Reynolds got Channing Tatum
to come back as the version of his gambit.
That almost was like
they never actually made
the Channing Tatum Gambit movie,
but they're doing some sort of cameo scene
making fun of that during Deadpool three.
but it does sound like
Marvel has been trying
to get Chris Evans
to come back for a while now.
And most likely the movie
that they were talking to him
about was not Captain America four because
they're releasing that movie next year.
and Chris
Evans keeps saying that
that would be way too soon
to come back and see Captain America.
so more likely he was referring to
coming back in Avengers six secret wars.
It seems like that
movie also got delayed until 2028,
which is another five years away.
Which obviously sucks.
Don't want to wait that long for it.
but that would make it almost ten years
after Avengers endgame.
Technically it'd be ten years
after Infinity War.
doesn't that feel like a crazy long break
between Captain America performances
for him? Like talk to Hugh Jackman
Patrick Stewart.
They're coming back as Wolverine
and Professor X from their X-Men movies.
Chris Evans.
Coming back in Secret wars
would be an even longer absence
than their absence from the Logan movie
right now,
I think the current record holders for
that are Mark Hamill in the Star Wars
Holy Trinity.
They're like the current leaders
in terms of movie actors
who have played their characters
the longest with the longest gaps
between movies.
There's was about 32 years
between Return of the Jedi
and returning in The Force Awakens.
Patrick Stewart and Hugh Jackman
will be coming back after the Logan movie
that's only been seven years if they're
able to release Deadpool three in 2024.
So it's not even that long.
technically two.
They're not coming back as the exact same
versions of the characters
in the Logan movie.
They'll be from the A38 universe
or another universe.
Let me know in the comments, though,
if you'd rather see Chris Evans,
Captain America, come back in secret wars
or a version of Captain America,
even if he's from another universe,
or would you rather see Chris Evans
come back, as is Johnny Storm?
Because those would be
two very different types of cameos.
you rewatch those old Fantastic
Four movies, and his Johnny Storm
just feels like a way more over-the-top
comedic type of character,
kind of like a hardcore
version of Robert Downey
Jr's Iron Man wise cracking in sarcasm
one of the reasons why
Marvel probably delayed Secret Wars
a little is to give themselves
time to figure out all those multiverse
cameos and actors returning again,
because that movie is meant to be
an even bigger swansong for all the legacy
characters like Fox, Marvel,
even the Sony Spider-Man actors
like Andrew Garfield and Tobey Maguire,
kind of the way that Avengers endgame
was a big swansong for the original six
Avengers.
Kevin Foggy wants to do that
for the original legacy actors,
and that's going to be Avengers
Secret Wars,
where they put together a multiverse,
Avengers team of all these legacy actors
that's how we're getting Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man on an Avengers team
with Hugh Jackman's Wolverine.
there's so many deleted scenes in attempts
at crossovers between Cinematic Universe
like Sony's Spider-Man movies,
the X-Men movies from back in the day.
They can finally pay off in secret wars.
That's my fault, I guess. Spider-Man.
I'm the one who brought you. Hi.
What's going
on? Ah, I'm going to squash ya.
Why? Stop. You know Spider-Man.
You can trust him.
there were also a lot of people wondering
if Chris Evans would return his old man
cap in something like Captain America four
because they had all those teasers
and theories
during Falcon and Winter Soldier.
It sounds
like when they made those actual episodes,
Marvel was optimistic
about getting Chris Evans to come back
so they could pay that scene off.
But there's all kinds of Easter
eggs baked into that.
there's the idea that old man cap
is living out there somewhere, retired,
just chilling out like a moon base,
an actual moon base.
A lot of people wondered
if that would wind up being Nick Fury's
saber space station.
clearly, Anthony Mackie's version
of Captain America knows where he is.
There's also the idea
the watcher has a moon base
on the blue side of the moon
that debuted in the Fantastic Four comics.
So maybe that's something
that they'll have Easter eggs
for during the live action
Fantastic Four movie
that's coming up with like the live action
version, the watcher coming back
They actually just had live action
watcher during I Am Groot season two.
I didn't do episode videos for that
because they were just like
a 15 minute collection of shorts.
But it was Jeffrey Wright coming back
from the What If series, I am the watcher.
Your guide
through the vast realities of time.
And today
we bear witness to a monumental prophecy
How does he keep doing that?
I always assumed that
if they did Live Action Watcher again
and we knew they do him eventually
after Guardians of the Galaxy 2,
did they just make it Jeffrey Wright's
version from what if because they had
a lot of Easter eggs for what if versions
of characters in the live action movies.
bit right now with everything
that's been going on
with the strikes
and everything at Marvel behind the scenes
and them trying to sort of correct
the like basically make better
Marvel movies.
On the whole,
It sounds like if there is any old man
cap stuff in Captain America four,
it'll just be the characters
referencing him.
I don't expect him
to be a big part of that movie
They've already got
all this adamantium stuff going on.
This whole subplot with them
discovering adamantium on TMX body
that dead, celestial in the Indian Ocean
then all the thunderbolt Ross Red
Hulk stuff in the World War Hulk stuff
that they're trying to set up for Bruce
Banner's version of The Incredible Hulk.
I know.
A lot of you
also want to see a Captain America series
showing his mission
to return the Infinity Stones
to each of the time periods
that they stole them from.
After Avengers Endgame.
But back when that movie came out,
when Endgame came out,
the Russo said Marvel could always
turn it into a series or a movie.
do not hold your breath on that, though.
Just because Marvel is so focused on
Anthony Mackie
being the main version of Captain America
right now,
even Chris Evans said like,
No, no, no, he's Captain America now.
I'm not Captain America anymore.
Marvel is not going to suddenly do a DC
kind of thing
where they have like
a bunch of versions of Batman
running around in different movies
at the same time.
So they're not going to do the same thing
at Marvel
with a bunch of versions
of Captain America
running around at the same time
in multiple movies
The problem
they run into with stuff like that is that
even if you're like a longtime hardcore
fan, you have no problem
following all that stuff.
Casual audiences
just get way too confused
when you see a bunch
of different versions
of the same character running around.
So which movies or series
do you want Chris Evans to come back for?
It could always wind up being some movies
after Secret Wars two,
like when they head into Marvel
Phase seven.
That sounds like
it'll be more of a hardcore X-Men
focused phase, like the Mutant Saga.
remember, Chris Evans is very young
right now in present day.
Even if he waited another ten years
to come back,
he wouldn't look that much different
than he did during Avengers Endgame.
Marvel's
also brought the original Captain America
Steve Rogers back multiple times.
Even De-Aged the character
back to his younger bodies.
the comics have done
way crazier things for a long, long time.
Big reminder though my Loki season
2 episode videos will start soon.
My Associate Episode
six video will post next.
Be sure to enable alert for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
click here for my Ahsoka Episode
6 video onto the link
As soon as I post that and click here
for my Loki Season 2 Episode 1 Video.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!